Welcome to the OMR podcast with
Philipp westermeyer
in the 73rd
financial year, but I don't think
I've ever
had a time when I
would have dared to make a forecast for the next
ten years as little as I do right now,
which is from the deepest black to the most
blooming  pink is
possible
and it depends on the
attitude to the cleverness or
stupidity of mankind how it
goes on for about two years
I've been working on meeting one of the
probably most successful
German entrepreneurs of all
time for the podcast and
today it worked out for me, of
course  Very spectacular day I
left Hamburg this morning and
then via Würzburg to Künzelau that's
here in the Hohenlohe or in the
Hohenlohe region that
actually means a bit nowhere
between
Stuttgart Frankfurt Würzburg in the
country and here is a company 85,000
Employees of the world will be there
one  professional legend and when I
arrived here I was first brought to an
art forum and then I went in there
and there were pictures that you ca
n't believe so Picasso and Warhol and
in Beckmann the crass
artists in general of the last time that
he has collected are but then
The colleague there only told me a few pictures
from 18,000 he is also the
second successful or largest
art collector in
Europe whatever that means in the end he
built up a company and I wanted to take the
opportunity to talk to him for an hour
to learn how he did it
what does he believe in how does he structure
his sales, above all, what is the main
thing in his company is
sales is built on it, in the
end it sells, she also says herself the
same podcast Screws and products
are actually
not really interchangeable and what principles have
led them  we are the world today
how does he look at Amazon even if
he maybe there  ht doesn't have a big
answer to give but what are
principles for him
and what does he want to leave behind there
we were spoken and yes certainly one of
the probably most impressive
guests here in the podcast it's
probably one of the
greatest days since I've been doing this podcast
for a long time  years because one
of the most successful
entrepreneurs we have had or experienced in the
tenth when
did you actually realize we
started many, many decades ago
that your entrepreneurial
activity could lead to such a large company,
no, that to America, I don’t know  I
just managed
[laughter]
Arrange simply my father died in 1954
the company was young he founded it in 1945
and when he died there were two
employees besides me and him and
so there were three of us when he
left
and today  it's 84
85,000
but at some point on this journey it
must have become clear  en what I'm doing here is going to be
so big that it's
already of European stature by now
oh that's what made everyone so
I've always been quite a curious
person and wanted to know what's going
on what I'm behind the mountain what's around the
corner and then I have  I of course
already presented certain goals to me for
the next year and the one after that and for the next four five years
and
when they were then fulfilled that was all the
more
[music]
to me how much of the success you have
now is because this work
reliability discipline and how much
is  in the end
the right product, luck, coincidence, things
that you can't be responsible for,
so
I do believe that you simply waste a certain amount
of luck,
but
on the other hand,
I do believe that 70 percent
of the success was simply
the effort it was the really good thing
I have succeeded in getting a feel for what has obviously also developed for
people  to
find those who were exceptionally
loyal who
found themselves above
average in this company and
felt comfortable in other
words the working
atmosphere played a major role right from the start
it was characterized by
a certain harmony by
striving for
justice and honesty  to be
predictable
and
also
to have fun, well, I was young,
I mean
, starting at 19 or 20 years of age, you
’re actually still a boy, and then we
had quite a lot of kidding and partying at the trade fairs in the evenings
this combination of
having work
in continuity combined with a
certain ease
in the realization with a certain
cheerfulness
that appealed to the people
I gave them a lot of freedom I built
the whole thing very decentralized and in
the end it was
how should you say no  again
advice from
obligatory  elation and fun and
such a combination is of course
unbeatable as a
corporate culture if people
don’t
take the whole thing too seriously and work
with a certain cheerfulness
and
don’t
take the whole thing too fanatically
on the other hand, but still the
goals  want to achieve together
that's a mixture I would like to say
that still characterizes
our corporate culture today
, but toughness is also part of
it you can read it,
I think you can read intensive letters
or it's also so
structural in your sales department that if
someone does not reach the sales targets
which is measurable that then there are
consequences other company vehicle at
once or something similar there are
anecdotes yes of course the
performance was
demanded in the end and in the end of
course only the
companies that did the job survived
the others
looking for a smart job
never felt comfortable here they
usually moved on on their own
because I had a very
spectacular case not so
long ago herisch now maybe two three
years ago
in a company in the USA what
we have there because we have a lot there  we
make several billion
annual sales in the USA
that was a smaller unit
and things just did
n't go forward
then it
just got too stupid for the regional manager
then he fired the entire management team
from new
people and so he did the whole thing
The management team was completely replaced,
I was crazy after they were all
gone, things suddenly
didn’t go up quite as well, so
you can see if you have
the right people
and the right combination
in the corporate culture,
then
things actually run by themselves
, you can say and you will  we
last year
17.1 billion so over 17,000
million
turnover  tz made
and were able to bring in 1
1 billion, i.e. a thousand or
1100 million in profit
input
tax, of course, these are
dimensions that I would never have
dreamed of as a young man that I
would
get there we will be
so close to the 20 billion
turnover this year  Nothing significant has
happened in the last few months,
so I fear that the fourth quarter
could lead to a major recession worldwide
and if that happens then this
statement of 20 billion will of course not apply,
but 19 will be and then the result will be
well over a billion
logically, please, significantly more
than a billion results will
probably be in the direction of 2 billion
results, in any case, that's over
a billion, I think it will be
the product they sell, the
products they sell, we're
actually not that unique
, they were at the beginning  Screws are
now 160,000 glau  be me
or 180,000 products but none of them
products where you say they only have them they
only exist there that means they
differ or that the success
does not come so much from the product
but also my perception is very
strong from the sales department like you
doing what they sell of course,
sales had a large part to play and
you are right, in principle, there
are mostly forest and meadow products
on the wallpaper that we sell, but
oops,
with our products you
notice that screws are not screws and that nuts are
not nuts  and a screwdriver is
not a screwdriver, so we are
at the top in
terms of quality, we only offer heavy,
solid products, and if
the tool we sell
costs 20 percent more than the
competition, but lasts twice as
long, then it's still good  stinks cheap in
the end and according to this principle that
obviously proves its worth I sometimes we
have there too  h
corresponding graphics Ms.
Schneider can perhaps give you later
Ms. Schneider is in the room with
the graphics maybe you can
get one right away
and
tell the sales department they are
so good at what is also the strength
of will what is  since the crucial
how do you get a
sales organization to
perform like this that gives me
success factors obviously what
are the two three where I say those are
the most important
first of all the role model
so we organized the store into the visions
after
wood processing companies
metal processing companies
car repair business and so on, and
in these districts
monthly circulars are then customary
monthly conferences which are then attended
by the smaller circles
than in
most of the 15 salespeople, for example,
who hold a district conference with their district manager
and there is
then again the area-
owned property  And who then looks after about 10
such districts,
so the whole thing is relatively
tightly organized, I would like to say,
and then of course there are
[music]
parts of the income that
are paid on a performance-related basis, so the percentage of
this is relatively high, which
means these field workers are
almost small self-employed  Entrepreneurs
do they
earn a lot they earn a lot they don't earn that much they
don't earn that much and
that's the
main feature
then the turnover lists are of course
published
and that gives a certain
boost that nobody
wants to be the last it's like in the Bundesliga
nothing and
that also shows what you can do
and then it
arouses a certain ambition that he
says what he can do, I can do that
too and
then the hours are also
used I mean there were and
probably still are cases
where the field service star is  a bit
comfortable and
means the four five hours i was his
day i ge  Yes,
there are such cases when there are a few
good customers who are
supposed to lead to fulfillment almost automatically,
but that's not normal and
the whole thing isn't
geared towards coercion and urge and
pressure
, you have to do it, you
absolutely have to, we offer  then
we offer nice incentives so we have
a success club we have a
top club
the look of success those are the means of
success they then go on a
three-day trip
once a year and I would like to say the stars are then there for
two weeks with their
partners and their wives
on a trip that goes to Bali or
somewhere else so to the whole
world
ship trips are back
that
is of course a certain point
that the
[music]
sellers are encouraged to take part and
meet their numbers because we of
course
talk about them in our corresponding periodicals
Report club trips with beautiful
pictures and then she always says it
So Fritz, make
a bit of progress so that we'll be there next
time
, I mean it's this
playful component that I
talked about before and I
mean it's great trips to
Rio or something and
when they come back  and
just tell your colleagues what you have
experienced then of course they want to be there next
time and they should
also fulfill it there is a statement from them
or at least I
read that in the research that they say the
success of the company is 90%  Sales
5%
IT and 5% all the rest
yes you can put it that way above all
at least miracles of importance in terms
of importance
I mean that is of course not true in terms
of the number of hours but in terms of
importance it is true
but I have to say it
takes  the importance of the field service has decreased
in recent years because of
whether customers are
tending more and more to ordering via the
Internet, i.e. us  he i job is
already making 25
percent of the turnover in some of
the companies the seller still gets the
commission if the order comes from his
area from his geographic area
it doesn't matter whether he does the job
himself or via the e-shop
But in fact the importance of the
field service is
declining in favor of ishops
, this is the biggest change the company has
experienced in the last since it was founded,
from the structure to the outside, i.e. sales in
the classic form and now
Internet operation, I already have
a very important change  that we are going
through, you can put it like this
[music]
the whole of society is being driven more and
more
in the sense of AI, artificial intelligence
, almost in the direction of computers
and robots and the
Internet and
automation,
which I recently said
in an interview request there
was asked how will we live in 30
40 years and then I have
something
crazy f  formulated and said
I can
imagine that if anything is still there,
if
we are not now in the Big at the beginning of the third
world war and afterwards there will be
nothing left after the atomic bombs have been
thrown, but if it
runs reasonably reasonably from the side
I can imagine that when you are 40 you
only have four days a week
and maybe 20 years later you will only work
three days a week and let
the computers and robots do the rest
, so that means the
[music
] physical effort of humans will
decrease  in favor of the
robots and
in favor of the internet but the human being
that was or is also their great
strength with all the
intensification and the
sales performance in the end the
fluctuation is below 15% I have
seen that is already very little so
the people are then  really in
faithful well because of
course we have turnover rates in the back office in some
companies  of two
three percent so nobody
is doing so well and so
we attach great importance to it I
just said goodbye to
an employee in Friedrichsruh the evening before last
who has worked for 50
years and warns a
group of maybe 50
people colleagues and so on and we
then celebrated his farewell and
that happens very often not at the age of
50 but at the age of 35 or 40
that I'm so routine that's very
often I'm a good role model I've been
working for this company for 73 years now
makes them  don't you sometimes
worry when you see that the
most valuable companies in the world today,
Amazon or Microsoft or Google, that they
are all probably much younger
, that
some of the people working there are half their age, so how do you
look at these companies
?  no, of course you have to make provisions for the
future, so I
know exactly how
things will continue after me, that's for sure  and
will soon be
published somewhere, so there will be some
changes in the upper committees,
but that's all done without hectic and without
much
I'll stay in my position as
long as I can and will
appoint two deputies who
are already in the  companies have important
positions and
based on the knowledge that I
have found that I have worked with them over the 2030
years, I then give them
power over the company
what would you say to
Amazon to Google about these digital companies
that he partly  are so completely different
from being listed on the
stock exchange many investors
very big growth targets
some younger people how do they look at these
companies
well
you know I always
initially only looked at our company
and didn’t pay much attention
to what the environment is like  others I make
[music]
that's not new generation those
companies they called and
that  it's correct I think that
's fine
[music]
our company is of course
more traditionally oriented,
for example I attach importance to the fact that
the
senior managers in conferences
wear ties during the conferences,
it
's unthinkable for Google or Amazon
to take care of something like
that
but it's these little subtleties
that ultimately give us a
certain amount of respect
from our business partners,
you know, the idea behind it is
n't that she just wants to see him
and has a rope around her neck, but the
idea is
I with a
business partner, it doesn't matter if  Customer or
supplier or otherwise with the authorities or
with anyone,
I feel that it is
simply disrespectful when I
approach the other person in a certain leisure look because such babble inhibits babble and
and I mean when a
ship of a global company
marches to Ms. Merkel
to a  Meeting
without a tie then e  I
just find it inappropriate and almost
an insult to the person I am
talking to,
whether that will still be the case in ten years for
me anyway because I am me now
and
it is logical that
my work is coming to an end
automatically but
it should be  go further
and then what the new group management
does, whether they say now we'll cut
the old braid and
tip the obligation to wear a tie, you
can do that during carnival,
how do you generally look at the
generation of those who are in
management today in many companies or  also
in politics people between 40 and
50 or 35 partly and 55
how do you see it is a noticeably different generation yes oh you know they are not
that much different
either
[music]
net net
[music
] it just comes  but in the end
on the hand to the answer to the question
how is the success and
everything else then pushes into the
background not so
I mean
So if I have to have the say, you know
that I'm no different today than I was 50
years ago, that the children just strive after their parents
, that's not much different
when you observe today,
the children from the medical families go to the university and study
medicine and
[  Music]
where the father is also CEO somewhere,
then the junior is studying business administration and
it hasn't changed that much, so
[music]
I can't see any world-
changing change compared to 30, 40, 50
years ago, there is
maybe a little bit among young people
more rebellious than
was the case in the past, but on the
whole young people are already
sensible citizens
and I can't tell that
there are major
world-shattering changes going on in the culture
, so
the young people were always
rebellious and always opposed them a bit
Parents asked and knew better that
was the case 300, 500 years ago and it
won't change either  ern how is
your feeling or your view of the
future of Germany, for example, one
is still for would
big market I think you still make 40 percent of
your sales in
Germany now there is a lot of talk
of rejection worlds  Change
you just talked about recessions
what what do you expect
for Germany in the next five to
ten years
that is a very difficult question
the answer is even more difficult
so it's kind of
a range I would like to say
where I can't
anymore  would dare
to predict what it looks like
, on the one hand,
they may have a
nuclear wasteland in front of them,
in the worst case
up to four days a week with
even more free time and even more
fanfare and even more Oktoberfest hustle
and bustle and
festivities festivals festivals
so as I said, since I have everything in it and
that will depend on how
people shape the future  So
that's I think I'm now
in my 73rd
year of business but I don't think
I've ever
had a time when I
dared to make a forecast for the next
ten years as little as I do right now
that's from the deepest black to  to the most
blooming pink
possible
and it depends on the
attitude to the cleverness or
stupidity of mankind how it
goes on they follow quite closely what,
for example, someone like Elon Musk
does and says no,
I just know that he works around with rockets
and cars  Tesla yes,
but
otherwise I think I'll read an article
in Der Spiegel tomorrow or something, but that
I would say now, I have to emulate the mast now,
I
'm much more concerned with modesty,
I'm concerned with reluctance
towards the employees
of the entire company
public
and I think that's gotten us very
far too, people see
that the arrogance in this
The company will
not have a home
that is actually my
main task today, to
keep arrogance at bay, because
if you compare our development with the
development of many
competitors, we have of course made
incredibly good progress, absolutely
I think there are the numbers here, you have to come here, I mean
them  have now become very, very wealthy
the company is one of the
most successful companies in
Germany or in europe no doubt
i mean we have competitors who have been
messing around with a sales performance for ten years
and only manage to improve
it a little after 11 years
but there  If you compare that, we make
significantly more profit today than the
sales we make today and that
is not the result of arrogance
but of modesty. Success is
important to you in the sense that there is an
anecdote in your biography from Mr.
Timmerberg where it is described that I
believe  her grandson in egg  sends an SMS
when the new forbs list comes out with
the richest people in the world on
it and shouts at it briefly so your
grandson writes you
where you are at the moment
really quite nice
I mean
the two
older grandchildren Benjamin and Sebastian,
both of whom are now  mine are already around 40
one of them had an MBA and was
therefore also well trained great has had a
great career
they are interested and they
don’t look specifically at the color list now
but they mainly orientate themselves
on the internet today so they do
n’t need a newspaper they have everything open  your
laptop and your family will follow you
at some point
where in the top management of the company
yes yes of course yes yes so
Benjamin and Sebastian will be on the
supervisory committees
they are already
on board sebastian is on the advisory board there will group and
Benjamin is on the committee that I
lead the supervisory board of the foundation so the
highest body of the group is the
sc  hon in there as a member and
I will continue to support both of them. Do
you believe that it works well, so
you do it, but I think a
bit of an entrepreneur like you
? It
would be in football  The exception is talent,
which is actually pretty low, as in football.
Beckenbauer's son is not Beckenbauer.
Messi's son is probably not
Messi  it's over she'll
still experience it ne keep watching
when
you think about the family in Italy with
Fiat it always worked well that there was
an adnelli at the top and
[music]
now let me do it if  I
don't do it alone,
we do it as a team, we discuss a
lot with each other in the management bodies
and above all, such things are not
simply given orders, they are worked out
together with the top
management, the
advantages and disadvantages are weighed up
and
yes, then you have to see what will come of it
and sell the company or put it on the
stock exchange, that was
certainly the case everywhere for decades  every
now and then a suggestion was made to
them by bankers but apparently never
what they seriously considered
no I never considered not my advertise
today 7 billion own funds
7000 million
that
is an equity ratio of 45%
measured against the balance sheet total
and
it even exists  no reason why we
should also go public, we
are actually represented on the stock exchange
with bonds, so we issue
them to laypeople again and again, that is anyway a
very unusual specific feature that
a partnership, which we
are, is for a GmbH & Co KG that the
bonds are issued on the stock exchange and that
works for us now  t for 20
years and we have the best ratings
so there was a pool gives us a
stable rating and
what I am concerned with the capital market
knows that it
is not absolutely bombproof
when you read about them and try to
understand what the influencing factors are
were you from where you got your ideas of
corporate management
then you quickly come across Mr.
klausewitz that was a a person a in
the end yes
general and author who impressed you myself
yes i interesting this Clausewitz who
haunts me again and again i only intend to
a  A few days ago I read from some interview
of someone of the same general
that he still quotes the same joke
in
connection with the
Ukraine
war  A guiding principle or
core rule that you would particularly like to
mention says this is typical of
k  lauselwitz
old man said so much and i mean i
'm not a military man is a historian i
wasn't a soldier was a white born
and was a
private soldier i just know that
a general is higher than a
non-commissioned officer
but
i don't know much more and
[music]
Nevertheless, Clausewitz has of course established
principles that are
still
valid today when you look at the
latest developments in this Ukraine
war, it
is typical for Klausewitz to
simply completely surprise the enemy with
a completely different
action
that was announced
and set up completely differently than before  as a target and so that
the forces of the enemy are in
the wrong place and you can almost
walk through it, so to speak, in a
different place,
I mean, you can of course apply such
[music]
opinions and comments
to
business life
and I have that again and again
realizes,
for example, the defense of a
imperial fortress
that was often quoted from
my speeches, Clausewitz also
published it extremely and it
's interesting that you can use it in exactly the same
way in business life
, i
mean
that Karl von klausewitz
in the
office libraries of the top
executives a lot  is not represented
enough because you can learn a lot from his principles for the
corporate strategy too. An
example that is then gladly taken
is that I think you
have explained your tear strength from Würth
are the craftsmen and in order to confuse the opponent you
have them in the industrial sector
Prices made very, very low
so that all your competitors had it
very difficult to assert themselves there
but were distracted and you
can concentrate on the craftsmen in peace
sens is you know
everything I have of course
but that’s right or that’s
exactly how it is
how did it succeed in the still except
about  sales the brand will
be built as my what role
does sport or art play, for example, are
also big elements in your life
well basically, of
course, art and culture play an
important role in the brand, can we
perhaps say a few more words later
but the basic basis is of
course that the brand is
identified with absolute
top quality,
so we only offer a very rough,
heavy, solid quality
and the customers also associate that with
the
brand  five or
ten percent times more expensive competition again
if the product lasts twice as
long as that of the competition we are
still stinking cheap if
the customer pays ten percent more for this product
but can use it 100%
longer then he has to  bought us very
very cheaply
but they are also building up the brand about it
, they just said s  o
to some extent they consciously have large art collections at all locations or in many large art collections directly in the offices or at the state branches, some of which are
huge museums I believe are one of the
largest art collectors in Europe 18,000
items in their collection and that
is also a business idea behind it
I think or
yes
I mean that in
the beginning it
was of course
also an
escape from the
daily stress, I would like to say so
if I could travel every day with
a friend
to an artist and
observe his work and
was allowed to examine his works then that was just
vacation  that was relaxation that was
joy and then of course that
had an influence on the
corporate culture
how
different the individual artists
are in character, so there are artists who are
meticulous like
surgeons in their studio and have
everything clean every pen is
arranged parallel to the other  there it is
again  other ones are where it
looks like at the blacksmith
and
yet in
the end great art comes out of both studios so these
are such
wonderful experiences,
acquaintances and friendships
developed,
for example I was good friends with Christo
and then until the same  concerns the
gallerists
with whom you also get to know well over time
they become
good acquaintances a few even friends and
[music]
yes that is simply the customer point
counterpoint to everyday life not but they
also want
to lure customers here in the country to Künzelau
, so to speak  I have a huge museum
, so it was just there for a short time, very
impressive, what artists from
Picasso and Warhol and Max Beckmann
and really everything there
that has names and has an idea behind it that
you show the people something, the
employees  and also the customers exactly,
so I mean that these
activities in the field of
art I always have
in scope  field of companies built up in
France, for example
Hamburg and a beautiful museum when
Erstein in Switzerland several museums
and
look in Denmark and so on
that makes
us happy in the company and makes
the visitors happy so
there are always comments that
people stop  say very positively
that there is something like that out there in the country
and then we also have the
Philharmonic, the
[music
] I want to say in all modesty
that they are a real top orchestra
and the crazy thing is I
recently had a concert where
Tiedemann was there when  Conductor
and then I met a complete stranger in the toilet
and he explained to me that he had come all the way from
Oldenburg to hear this concert
but I have to imagine
from Oldenburg to Künzelsau that's
not exactly the way to the bakery
and that's
how it will be today  but
benevolently seen and observed everywhere and also
gives the company
a
cultural component  te that goes in the direction of
[music]
airiness
radiates a certain joie de vivre
that you not only look fanatically at
sales and wins but
also know how to appreciate the beautiful sides
of life
and the customers also
appreciate that we would to
[music  ]
evening concerts or when they
come to the museums, they
are also happy about these
installations
and, to be quite honest,
I of course see it as
very favorable
advertising for the company, I mean we
are so often represented in the
culture sections of the daily newspapers and the
press  you shouldn't
underestimate what it means for
the level of awareness of the company, so
I found it clever because
the level of art is
incredibly high, so the best
artists in the world are by name and that
then shines on the brand like that
my feeling was a bit off,
that's exactly it, it
's not just a feeling, it's there  ss
I say the fact as well as their tactics
their strategy yes
and I observe they also do the same
in sports so that they consciously I
think they only say team sports because it is
about the team but they also promote
successful sports teams with Word
in order to synchronize where there is success
,
yes, we get
fat and yes very strong
winter sports as a whole and
that is competitive sports, you can safely
say
performance in sports performance in the company
that associates very well and goes
well together
when you have built up a company like this  and
created such means what kind
of responsibility
do you feel there now or what would you
say to other people who are perhaps not quite
as successful but at least have
more means than others
where is the limit you have a
responsibility that is compensated with  the
taxes with the jobs that you
provide with the promotion of the
region is there  beyond that, we think
about it
, well,
I mean, you can't
just
think about these 84,000 jobs every day, it would be the
same if you expected a
Lufthansa captain or Air France
captain
to think about the fact that 300,400 people
live
[music]
in the plane  and I am
responsible for them getting to their destination
safely,
but
I recently had a lengthy
conversation with my dear
wife,
whether she likes it or not, this
responsibility is there and
I mean if it came after a
military conflict,
I can't imagine that  I
would settle down here and would leave the
employees alone, I mean,
I see that as an
obligation towards the employees
to do the same thing I
expect from them
and maybe even feel beyond the company
for the country or for people
outside the company  are also
a responsibility
good would come back to the area
Inducing arrogance I have no
legitimacy
[music]
to speak for the country or to do anything,
but of
course our company is
not only well known here in this region, but
we also do
many things with donations and so
on that
ultimately have an effect on the public, be it now  that somewhere a
new
indoor pool has to be renovated or something like
that. In that case
, I said a 1.5 million
as part of the renovation contribution,
and otherwise if there
are children’s festivals or schools or something like that,
then of
course it’s the company
with certain things  Donations
last question when you read
and researched about them then you get the feeling
they have led a very, very perfect
life also a relationship your wife
who until today there no separation no
younger companion none of it
the company the whole work the
art collection
your interests in  in a variety of
areas there is then globe in the
museum sa  g I where all your travels are
on it where you have been all over
the world madness traveled the whole world
anyway what do you regret what would you
say you would do differently if
you started again or if you were
20 30 years or 40 years younger
would not be optimal
so right
away I can't
think of anything significant that I would do differently I mean
I'm married to my wife at
66 Congratulations and
[music]
I often said to
acquaintances or those who got
divorced leave it
alone  thing wo
n't be exactly the same in five years so
I'm there more for continuity and and
it was also worth it I mean I
'm also very grateful to my wife
you know we're so close today
that I want to say the word in
the  mouth it's just wonderful
how we harmonize together and
yes we have been particularly close in the last 18
months because my
wife has a serious operation  who went
well thank god and
[music]
i just
gave her a kiss goodbye she
lay down and is
taking her nap he will thank you very much for your time thank you very much for
letting me be here for the
interview i think there's quite a bit  of
inspiration for the listeners in the
philadelphia generation
thank you very much thank you also thank you
Philipp Westermeier